other readings from five birthdays I'm
moving person the director of business
development by inviting India we are
glad to have collaborated with Institute
of genetic engineering could cut up to
bring your three month long workshop on
in a sense for biologists the program
will start on 3rd September 2013 and who
or did eat noble 2090 in the course we
will discuss on topics like big data
informatics genomics transcriptomics
with a genomics and machines oriented
along with the courses taken you have
the opportunity to use our an applicant
platform which has a point-and-click
consistent interface that anyone with
basic computer skills can use the online
workshops will be held on weekly and
bi-weekly basis from girls p.m. to 1
p.m.
Indian Standard Time 3 on-site workshops
will be held at the Institute of genetic
engineering Kolkata to pre-register for
the course click on the description box
below to know more keep an eye out on
our social media channels you get all
over so on Facebook Twitter Instagram
and naked what 80 objects
hope we see you in the classes
[Music]